bravely default 2 may look like your
standard turn-based rpg
but there is a lot more going on under
the hood if you've never played a
bravely default game
then 2 can be kind of tough so we've
compiled 8 tips to help you navigate the
world and give you the edge in combat
[Music]
before we get into it consider
subscribing to gamespot's youtube
channel and check out steve watts review
of bravely default 2.
alright let's get to it number 1
bravely defaulting the core combat
mechanics in bravely default are braving
and defaulting as the title of the game
implies braving allows a character to
attack multiple times in a row
while defaulting is a defensive maneuver
that stores an action point
the catch is that your characters can
only attack if they have zero or at
least
one free brave point or bp so if you go
full brave at the beginning of battle
they will go into turn debt meaning they
can't perform any actions for the next
few
turns you could play conservatively
taking only one action per turn but
battles will drag on
and you'll give your opponents more
opportunities to chip away at your
party's health
on the other hand you could go full
brave with all your party members but if
you don't clean up your opposition in
that opening phase you'll be leaving
your entire party
open for the next few turns success is
about finding a balance between braving
and defaulting another step in the right
direction
[Music]
number two defaultly braving so let's
dig into the numbers a bit more
as i mentioned before combat actions are
tracked with bp points
if a character's bp points are 0 or
positive then they have an
action if they are negative then that
character has to sit out a turn
as long as you have 0 or plus 1 brave
point you can go
full brave this lets you attack 4 times
in a row
however if you go full brave with only
plus 1 bp
that will set your party member back to
negative 2 bp that means you won't be
able to do anything
until you are back at positive bp this
is where defaulting comes in handy
by defaulting a party member is giving
up his or her action in order to defend
and more importantly bank a brave point
once you hit plus 3 bp
you can go full brave without going in
to turn debt for weaker foes you can go
full brave at the beginning
in order to knock them out quickly for
tougher enemies it's best to play a
little more defensively
the last thing you want is to be in turn
debt during an enemy onslaught
bravely seconding you probably thought
we were done talking about this but
there's a lot to cover
there are some important quirks when it
comes to this system that you should
know about
for example if you knock out an enemy
while braving your next attack will
automatically hit the enemy directly to
the right of it if the enemy you just
knocked out is on the far right you'll
automatically target the enemy on the
far
left i try to only use enough bp to
finish off an enemy
it's not terrible if your attacks spill
over to another enemy but it makes it
harder to aim for weaknesses
[Applause]
if you run out of mp while braving your
attack will fail and you'll waste brave
points
if an attack's text turns red that means
you won't have enough mp to perform that
move when it comes up
finally enemies can also brave and
default making certain encounters
particularly deadly
in order to check their bp press x there
are also certain abilities that cost
bp to use that means if a move costs 1
bp it will actually take up 2 bp
one to use the move and one to carry out
the action
number 4 combat tips with all of that
out of the way
let's talk about general combat tips
first off why lets you swing your sword
outside of battle
this can be used to cut grass or to
smack an enemy before entering a battle
we must make the most of this
opportunity
if you successfully hit an enemy with
your sword before battle then your party
will feel brave
meaning that they kick off the fight
with 1 bp otherwise they'll start at
zero
general rule of thumb is that if an
enemy runs away from you it's weak
if it charges you they are probably
strong if you're up against a foe you've
never seen before use the magnifying
glass item or the examined skill in
order to see the enemy's weaknesses and
hp
the freelance job automatically starts
with examine so you probably won't need
any magnifying glasses early on
[Music]
number 5 preparing for a fight although
magnifying glasses aren't super useful
early on
hp and mp restoration items are the most
efficient way to heal while exploring
the world is by using a tent
if you're exploring the world map a tent
will fully replenish your party's hp and
mp
unfortunately tents don't work in a
dungeon this means you want to bring
plenty of restoration items with you
before setting out if you aren't careful
a group of enemies can wreak havoc on
your party so make sure to stock up on
both items and equipment whenever you're
in a town
it's also worth picking up a few
teleport stones and ward lights
teleport stones let you warp out of a
dungeon and ward lights make it tougher
for enemies to spot you
number six jobs and sub jobs another key
feature of bravely default 2 is its
in-depth job system as you progress
through the game you'll unlock new jobs
which you can freely assign to party
members as main or sub
jobs jobs range from black mage to monk
and determine a character's look
move set and progression jobs each have
their own separate leveling track that
max out at 12.
as you level it up you'll unlock more
abilities both active and
passive keep in mind that only your main
job will level up
sub jobs allow characters to utilize
abilities and perks from another job but
they don't level up
when deciding which character should
have which jobs it's important to find a
main job and sub job that not only
complement each other but the party
member and their equipment
if you press y on the job screen in the
menu you can see the job's recommended
equipment
[Music]
number 7 passive abilities as you level
up you'll unlock passive abilities
however if you want to reap the benefits
of those passive abilities you need to
equip them to do that go to the main
menu and click on the abilities page
here you can equip passive abilities
that correspond to your equipped job and
sub
job you can only activate 5 passive
abilities at a time and the game will
not assign these abilities automatically
so it's worth checking this menu often
throughout your travels
number 8 miscellaneous tips honestly
there's a lot to cover with this game so
i'm just going to rattle off some tips
that
didn't quite fit in the previous entries
so here goes
use the exploration feature you will
passively collect a ton of useful items
when your console is in rest mode make
sure to check back at
exploration hqs in various cities to
collect your reward
don't worry the game will do a much
better job of explaining this feature
early on
most spells have two targeting options
before you cast a certain spell you can
press y to target
all enemies instead of just one if
enemies in a dungeon are running away
from you it's a good sign you're ready
to take on the boss
take on every side quest most require
little effort and offer
decent rewards the plus button lets you
speed up battle this is very useful when
you have to grind
and grinding you will do equip load each
character
can only carry so much be cognizant of
how much stuff you are equipping
any weight increases also show up blue
when you're equipment shopping so keep
that in mind
blue isn't always good i'm sure once
this goes up i'll have thought up a
dozen more tips
but if you have any questions feel free
to hit me up on twitter at jacobdeck or
leave a comment below and hopefully
someone in the comments can help you out
for more on bravely default 2 and other
rpgs don't forget to subscribe to
gamespot
[Music]
you